the latest single from German
electro-pop Pangloss Pelin spiel is
called Paris it's the first release from
their new album
let's get around us and leave it's about
a love affair that's falling apart I'm
getting bored but it's saved by Paris
Paris basically represents hope and it's
also a reference to the movie Casablanca
when they say we'll always have Paris it
means they can still save their
relationship monopoly says via console
even Manhattan
we really wanted there to be a theme
running through the album we took our
inspiration from various movies to tell
the story to create a whole storyline
storyline so why did the band shoot the
clip for a track called Paris in and
around Las Vegas the video shows them on
a classic American road trip
we did it deliberately
it's not about Paris as such it's about
how any place can be Paris we chose Las
Vegas because we felt it couldn't be
more different
dear Comte Acosta even has its own
Eiffel Tower wouldn't have thought he
hung the above my effort on Las Vegas -
Daniel and Colleen both come from stock
up on Lake Constance they started
playing in bands together as teenagers
and in 2006 they fell in love
and I like about Daniel is that he's
very honest and a very obese kind of
person they're positive us they said
they're howling what I like about
Colleen is that she's made me a much
more relaxed person
their big break came in 2011 when they
represented their home states in a
televised German song contest their song
itched secured them fourth place
the single went on to storm the charts
and struck gold like their debut album
move egg dish myth Mia
benzine lows was released in 2013 and
also reached the top 10 as much as they
love chart success what the band really
enjoys is performing live
beyond stages our favorite thing in the
world
we love the immediate feedback from the
audience and seen them respond to our
music forming live has had a big impact
on us in recent years and has been very
inspirational
in fact plea agreements espen yet
they're still going from strength to
strength lined up to support German
superstar Hellena Fischer on her
upcoming stadium tour they're sure to be
gaining armies of new fans
as we're looking forward to it playing
stadiums has always been on my list it
doesn't matter if we're headlining or
the support band a tour is just
something you have to do once
after that Glaspell and spheal will
return to headlining when they take
their new record on tour
you